conservatives Christians
pro-lifers white people even just mild
critics of gender ideology all regularly
receive threats including death threats
from political radicals and the threats
they face are not merely from Fringe
cranks top ranking Democrat politicians
have explicitly called for violence
against conservatives Congress lady
Maxine Waters has urged her followers to
push back on conservatives whenever they
see them in public to go to their homes
where their children sleep kamla Harris
and top staffers for Joe Biden bailed
BLM riers who had targeted civilians out
of prison Hillary Clinton told her
followers that it is impossible to be
civil with Republicans and if history
has taught us anything it is that if
Hillary Clinton threatens you with
violence you take that
seriously your life could depend on that
okay